light plastic
bags although the report adopted by Envy
confirms a pragmatic Vision towards
circular economy the reporter is well
aware that there are still differences
between the positions adopted in the
different Committees of this house with
the amendment tabled by my group the
reporter wanted to take a further step
towards a common balanced position on
the most controversial aspects of the
text first
on the ReUse aspect article 26 in
addition to the removal of targets for
the takeway sector already adopted by
the Envy committee the reporter proposes
that economic operators with a packaging
recycling rate of over 84 85% to be
Exempted from the ReUse obligation
striking a balance between increasing
targets and simply eliminating them
secondly with regards to the
restrictions of certain packaging
formats for the fruit and vegetables
that's Annex 5 line two the reporter
wishes to respond to AG concerns by
extending the scope of the packaging
format still authorized to single use
plastic free composite packaging so that
producers can continue to have a wider
choice of
Alternatives lastly with regard to
packaging restriction for the Ora sector
that's Annex 5 line three the text
adopted in Envy is already a well
balanced a complete derogation for micro
Enterprises a three-year defer for
applications of the measures uh on
flexibility granted to the member states
however in a spirit of
compromise the reporter wanted to add
rappers that they would be Exempted from
the band as it would be difficult to
replace them them with other
Alternatives this set of amendments is
for the raur the the middle ground that
only reconciles positions between groups
lending a robust text at the beginning
of inter institutional
negotiations on her behalf I would like
to thank all the colleagues for the
cooperation we have had so so far and
I'm looking forward to represent this
house in the further negotiations with
the co-
legislature uh so thank you then I
changed my hat because uh uh I think
there was a understanding that I would
have also one minute for myself because
then the combination that sort
of I Tred to get it to 30 seconds and I
just State then that one of the problem
we had was the uh and I probably Chang
to finish
one our real problem was um life cycle
an
analysis that can be done in many
different ways even small
changes how many wash Cycles how much
water how much energy each of these
changes the actual situation and changes
the result of the life cycle analysis
so uh life cycle in the the form that we
got it from the
commission gave us uh um problems that
we couldn't get over but we'll try to
deal with that in future thank you very
much thank you I'm sorry we were not
aware that you had your own uh hat um
for this
debate but we'll
continue on behalf of the ITR committee
patri
Toya thank you madam president thank you
commission it's a great honor for me to
represent the itri commission which has
worked very hard on this measure it's an
even greater honor for me to be
rapporter for a committee which has had
shared powers on a series of very
important Provisions we think that
overall this is positive we very much
share the objective of this regulation
which is to reduce packaging waste and
packaging and most of the measures incl
included in
it we have tried to bring some changes
in with a report voted on a very large
majority in itri so as to ensure that we
can conciliate the ambitious objective
set out by the
commission with reality the opinions and
observations state-of-the-art
research uh regarding the very many
extremely good things in the
report so as not to penalize the
excellent work which has been done in
recent years to improve the quality of
packaging to ensure that packaging the
market increasingly sustainable to
invest in Recycling Industries
Innovative
research
but and I think it would have been
unacceptable for the rest of the world
if we hadn't followed up on that this is
so it's important that we adopt the
opinions of the itay committee the
problem is however that the lead
committee simply took disregarded our
all our positions the speaker has been
cut
off thank
you now we have another opinion on this
report for the imco committee virgin
Jon thank you Madame President
colleagues now on the one hand we want
to bring things from New Zealand and on
the other hand we want to reduce
packaging so we're going to put a b on
all sorts of boxes and wrappings but if
I was a bureaucrat in Brussels I'd also
make sure that uh you know we did we
reduced even more by making bringing
even more absurd rules in if I was a
bureaucrat I wouldn't have Stakes
anymore we we could eat insects instead
I'd also put a ban on thermal cars and
uh lowcost flying and i' also put a ban
on Twitter and have General surveillance
in place and I would get rid of words
like Mr M and so on he she this is how
you know camela packaging is going to be
banned because somebody went to Bali and
saw some rubbish on the bdge of course
recycling is good and plastic is useless
but we already have a law in France so
why don't we just let the French live
freely in France and allow the Europeans
to live freely in Europe thank you thank
you for the
commission I give the floor to
commissioner
sinius honorable members uh thank you
for this opportunity to address you
today uh ahead of a vote that is crucial
for our environment our single Market
our Industries and our citizens and let
me start by thanking first of all
rapporter uh miss all Shadow reporter
the reporter of the three opinion giving
committees and uh the many of you who
have uh I also met uh over the last
months to discuss this
proposal dear members of the parliament
what we have on the table is a set of
ambitious rules to take packaging on
board uh our transition to climate
neutrality and clean circular economy if
we are to reverse the ever growing
amounts of waste and increase resource
efficiency in the packaging sector then
we have to be ready for a
change I'm convinced that this will be a
change for the better packaging is a key
sector where we can Empower citizens to
participate in the circular economy and
help create new business opportunities
the measures we propose they will
deliver cost savings to Consumers and
benefits for the environment commission
has worked very closely with all
stakeholders All actors we've listened
to the full range of issues concerns
that have emerged some of you call for
additional
flexibility in
particular on reuse targets mandatory
deposit and return systems and waste
prevention in
general however harmonizing Europe
packaging rules is a core objective of
this initiative reducing red tape
compliance cost and Market barriers
taking full advantage of the EU single
market and I'm convinced that we can
achieve the desired high level of
harmonization only if we keep the bar of
our ambition
High the latest data on packaging waste
show that we have broken a new sad
record between 2010 and 2021 our
packaging waste grew by more than
24% faster than
GDP and even faster than recycling
capacities in 2021 alow we saw the
highest increase indicate by 6% compared
to
2020 so this surge in packaging waste is
a clear sign of persisting wasteful
Trends in resource use driven by single
use in the we now generate almost 190 uh
kilog of packaging waste per person
every year so our proposal aims for
efficiency gains in the recycling sector
the absolute volume of packaging waste
for recycling will surely need to
increase but the clearly Trends are
showing and please not it recycling is
not
enough losses are inevitable at every
stage of recycling change and primary
materials are constantly needed to
complement what comes from the recycling
waste so we must do more to reduce gener
the generation of packaging waste more
to replace single use packaging with
Sustainable Solutions and help to roll
out reuse or refill
systems lastly dear colleagues let let
me recall our Industries are united in
their call for disregulation to come
into Force supporting our single Market
our citizens they expect decision from
all of us and they all say the earlier
the better and the commission agrees
thank you
thank you commissioner and now for the
agre committee the opinion will be
presented by salvator
Deo thank you president commissioner
tomorrow's vote on the packaging
regulation is likely to undermine The
credibility of the European Union
everybody in Europe wants this to be
more sustainable less packaging in other
words but we can't forget that this same
Europe has for many years now promoted
and supported research on recycling it
has also encouraged and trained citizens
to sort their waste we're now proposing
the opposite without actually thinking
about the enormous results which you've
achieved in terms of recycling what
could is likely now to become a parallel
Street which undermines our credibility
in the social economic and ecological
way so let's think about the food
industry
we need to be able to eat fresh tasty
and safe food without
waste if we are to do that we can't run
the risk of destroying whole industrial
sectors which have an enormous impact on
consumers I would appeal to everybody on
this we have to ensure that we come back
to Common Sense so as to ensure that our
political choices and environmental
choices be coherent and above all in the
interest of our
[Applause]
citizens
thank you and now we'll hear the
speakers from the groups first of all
for the EP group M Milano
Salini thank you today in Europe we have
an enormous quantity of waste derived
from
packaging but the quantity perhaps isn't
enough to justify the enormous extent of
the this legislation the vast majority
of packaging Rel Rel ated
waste is adequately dealt with by the
recycling industry the risk we're
running here as at this extremely
complicated and uh cumbersome
regulation will uh end up covering just
2% of the total volume of waste it's not
serious for us to devote so much time
and
money to regulations covering a sector
which and I'm talking about the food
sector now has already achieved an
enormous
amount the results achieved by that
sector have been quite extraordinary
obviously we haven't achieved the same
results in all 27 member states some
countries have made enormous progress in
terms of recycling others less
so others have been more successful when
it comes to reuse the fact is best
recycling practice cannot be disregarded
which is something this regulation is
trying to do we're introducing a concept
of recycling which has no scientific
basis and is which is not based on the
major principles which
we support and which we supported
negotiations on material neutrality
closed circuit recycling for example for
high quality recycling is another issue
which we have to deal with there are so
there are some substances which can work
within a closed circuit bottles to
bottles for example when it comes to
paper the closed circuit system simply
does not work you need a clo open cycle
for if we're to achieve high levels of
recycling so the whole system of cross
cating issues here first of all the
performance of IND individual countries
secondly protecting our recycling
industry which has achieved so much in
terms of Food Safety and
Security this is why we want these
negotiations to come back to have its
feet on the ground is to recognize
reality as Serv the colleague said let's
not simply disregard and throw away all
this important research done in so many
countries thank you darara Bart now for
the snd
group thank you very much Madame
President colleagues last week I got
post or I had a talk with a
12-year-old 12-year-old school girls
alna and Saina in dorf they were annoyed
that in the fruit and vegetable um
section of the super Market there was so
much packaging I asked myself what we
could do about this the reality that uh
the the girls are right we use to much
uh packaging for example to go cafe or
cucumbers or or whatever it is since
2010 our um consumption of packaging
waste in the EU has grown by 20% every
German uh masses 225 kg of waste that's
the same as much as as the weight of
three washing
machines many people in Europe are
annoyed about this a majority of
people calling on us to reduce the
mountain of waste I hope that the voices
of consumers will be heard in this house
as uh certain experts I have never been
U contracted by so many lobbyists some
of this has been on the board of
legality with pseudo science fake
studies they um so doubt and they
shouldn't be successful tomorrow
tomorrow we we can set the direction and
we can reduce our consumption because uh
we can't recycle us way out of our
mountains of um waste we we need rules
about um on excess packaging and rules
on
reuse we can make packaging more
sustainable we can have a whole program
for recycling because from 2030 or
packaging must be recyclable and more
recycled
material uh must be in um plastic
material we can um we can avoid
bisphenol and forever chemicals which
are come in contact with our food Sabina
and Anna those girls gave us hope that
more people more me Members would hear
their voice and tomorrow uh who is in
favor of whom in this
house
thank you delar Bard now for the renew
group Karen
Melo thank you I will speak Danish with
this law we can make sure we can have
harmonization of packaging rules uh
reduce our use of single use packaging I
would not to go through uh all the glass
uh in The Parks of uh Copenhagen because
there aren't enough requirements
or all the single use um takeaway
packaging I don't want to go through
Europe with um deposit bottles in my
packaging because these packaging the
deposit systems aren't mutually
recognized we want to make sure that we
don't destroy the possibilities for
small
Enterprises because the requirements
have moved from the producers to the
Distributors I would like to thank
Frederick Reese for the uh corporation
on Banning pasas in packaging so we will
ban these forever chemicals from our
food remember tomorrow that the
principle of Do no harm should apply
when we uh deal with the laws on our uh
reuse and and deposit systems in our
single Market thank you very
much thank you Miss Melo and now for the
greens European free Alliance Group
Grace o
salivan colleagues it shouldn't be a
surprise to you that the junk food
Barons are not a reliable source of
environmental
advice that lobbyists for plastic
corporations are not authorities on
sustainability
yet here we are debating whether we
should or should not tackle the mountain
of packaging waste piling up in our
towns and
cities all because of the corporate
Embrace of throwaway single use culture
and despite what those men in Ni suits
tell you we cannot recycle our way out
of this m
s if your single use plastic cup is
recycled into a single use plastic bag
it is not sustainable if your plastic
junk is wrapped for is swapped for
cardboard junk it is not sustainable and
if we continue to generate levels of
waste at current rates that is by
definition
unsustainable so car colleagues we have
to pull the brakes on our throwaway
Society the empty cardboard shipping
boxes the single serving shampoo bottle
for your single serving Hotel experience
the plastic wrapping for a single piece
of
fruit all this plastic is cheap this
cardboard is cheap this packaging is
cheap but the price for our future is
very very high
indeed thank
you thank you
Miss Sylvia
sardoni for the ECR group now Petro
fi and after that Sylvia sardon
thank you
president obviously we do agree with the
objective to reduce the amount of
packaging and waste materials in
particular in the perspective of the
need to reduce the amount of waste which
is being taken to landfill this is
important for the whole of Europe for
environmental reasons but also for
economic
reasons on this regulation which we
talked about in the Envy committee there
are three points I'm not very keen on
one of them is the fact it's a
regulation rather than a directive this
means that member states don't have any
room when it comes to choosing a
different way of doing this a different
Road forward the fact is Italy and
Belgium are very good when it comes to
recycling of differentiated waste others
in other
sectors I'll continue evaluation impacts
were produced but I think they're a bit
scanty they don't really focus enough on
the environmental social or even
environmental
aspects so I think they should be done
again the minimum recycling rate or
content and this is something which the
commissioner I think thinks is important
it's problematic we've
seen a very in vast
increase of 120 or 150% when it comes to
materials in Europe according to the
financial
times so the problem
here is that with the increase of
Transport costs and we've been talking
today about CO2 emissions and
hgvs together with
increase increase costs for
packaging so the fact
is we are actually expecting European
citizens to pay an enormous increase in
prices in supermarkets so that's
ridiculous that's crazy the people of
Europe don't understand this thank
you thank you the floor goes now to
syia this measure on packaging is
absolute Madness
you're going to push whole countries
into crisis Italy for example a model
country when it comes to Circular
economy we are European leaders or
indeed world leaders when it comes to
recycling Italy achieved European
objectives 7 years early this has
involved enormous Investments between
2021 and
2021 7 billion EUR have been invested in
separating waste and 4 billion when it
comes to uh Recycling and recovering
materials but once again we're going to
throw money away we are using more and
more plastic increasing uh waste
damaging health and increasing transport
costs U we've also heard talk about food
waste but this is a bit schizophrenic if
we are to fight against food waste
people suggest we should be having
smaller and smaller
packages there's no impact analysis of
any of
this which would actually demonstrate in
some cases a more important
environmental impact from reuse because
sometimes the packaging has to go
backwards and forwards it has to be
clean that means we consume water and
energy and we will also be closing then
companies and lead l firing of
workers so let me just say this to you
stop here don't go any further thank you
thank you very much just before I give
the floor to the next speaker I would
like to announce that we have already
nine uh persons for the catdi and I will
all take them but I close the list now
for the catdi and I give the floor to Mr
Z Pima Lopez
please thank you President we have to
reduce our uh waste uh packaging
waste and we do need
to be careful with the resources that we
use
and single use packaging as well will
have to be reduced there has to be I
mean there is a cost which is passed on
to the consumer at the end of the day
and there'll have to be Administration
and control at public level of the waste
uh in all uh sectors and we'll have to
think uh
about the efforts made in different
member states because we all have
different uh starting points and we have
different objectives but all of this
will have to be suited to each member
state of course and we need to be
flexible over town time so that each
member State can achieve its
goals and we need to do something for
those uh states that have a low
percentage of recycling to ensure that
they are helped and given the right
structures and infrastructure to do
that thank you
commissioner free water in restaurants
the POS possibility of using reusing
containers for food stopping waste of uh
packaging those are some of the
advantages of this packing regulation
for
Citizens recycling won't disappear but
recycling alone is not enough we have to
intervene at the source we have to
reduce the enormous quantities of waste
and to do this we have to promote
reuse so recycled plastic intility is
just SE 16% what are you talking about
Excellence those are lobbies putting
pressure on Italian members this is
indecent I say to you concentrate on the
opportunities which we can see new jobs
new
Industries don't theide of not
negotiating a minimum recycling level
what about
Excellence where are we excellent maybe
on paper maybe on
glass and this would be at the cost of
of all those recycling sectors which
work with
plastic MEPS and members of the five
star movement are committed to the
interests of our citizens but we have to
be interested to everyone's interests we
have to try to protect the interests of
those the weakest members of society
thank you very much next speaker is
Peter
ler
colleagues we must fight the um flood of
plastic and waste that's why we need a
regulation it's a single market for the
circular economy the member states who
haven't got much recycling so far must
do a lot more but the
commission I think has
overshot this
proposal has the spirit of Vice
President timman even though he's not
there give you two examples first online
trade we have a lot of uh Superfluous
packaging a lot of plastic but the
proposal uh is on paper which is treated
in the same way as plastic I know
companies which are uh moving from
plastic to paper shouldn't we support
them
secondly much more annoying for me the
proposal from the commission bands small
uh bags made from paper for sugar salt
pepper and confectionary colleagues this
morning I had a coffee this morning I
got these little packages in Strasburg
we can't
seriously ban something to the public
which we use ourselves we can't
seriously where we have so many problems
with the paper bags we got be dealing
with paper bags we have so many problems
I think we will vote down this nonsense
tomorrow then we'll have a good text let
us make uh tables table amendments in
that to to that end thank you next
speaker is Miss SAR s
please thank you very much uh president
commissioner now we see what is
happening and we see the increase in the
packaging on a daily basis in the
European
[Music]
Union you know what each person produces
about half a kilo uh and this is just
not
sustainable and is having a negative
impact on the environment so Solutions
innovative solutions need to be found
for reuse so so as to reduce the impact
on the environment and we have to create
uh some form of recovery system for
recycling and also invest in
Alternatives and more sustainable uh
materials to replace plastic for example
we need to as consumers in member states
make sure that we cooperate and
collaborate to work towards reducing the
use of these Plastics in this waste this
packaging to have a more sustainable and
a healthier environment next speaker is
Miss Elie Katan
please thank you president commissioner
colleagues it's very important that we
bring down the growing amount of
packaging waste in Europe practical
Solutions are need and separate
collection must be improved it's good
that we've achieved big uh improvements
on the commission proposal despite this
the environmental environmental
committee position would weaken the um
efforts by industry for the circular
economy current recycling problems have
to do a lot with plastic I can't accept
that the EU is um punishing the fiber
based material where recycling works and
where we get valuable raw materials no
one is against reuse but recycling must
be an equal alternative alongside reuse
the Finnish bottle deposit system
is an excellent example for the whole of
Europe at worst because of strict
demands and um Banning um U packaging we
will end up with more food waste
and we haven't had a proper
consideration of the objectives and the
environmental
impacts thank you next speaker is
Manuela
while we talking yet again about a law
on packaging and waste although 5 years
ago we adopted a directive the answer is
quite straightforward the quantity of
packaging in the European Union has been
exploding our the levels of packaging
have reached record levels this is why
an update of this legislation is
necessary it's now our responsibility to
ensure that we can find a solution which
is good for both people and nature in
particular we need ambitious obje Ives
for avoiding waste and reusing a
packaging unfortunately we've seen
there's a massive L there's massive
lobbing resistance against
this however reuse having precedence
over recycling is essential this is
important if we are to reduce our CO2
and other
emissions while at the same time
reducing the plundering of our natural
resources the destruction of environment
and the pollution of our air we should
finally do something to substantially
reduce the mountains of waste in the
European Union recycling alone is not
enough the legislation we voting on Now
is better than the status quo but it's
still too weak we in our views still
have an important task we must do more
to ensure that we have a sustainable
environmentally friendly future for our
packaging industry in
europea commissioner you know very well
that I like you a lot and I respect you
a lot but I must stop
with a difficult proposal I think you
should see within the commission who
brought this draft because clearly
someone is trying to make money on
something here because the draft
proposal it throws into the
bin dozens of years of education of
investment of searching for solutions to
actually have a close circuit economy
and suddenly there are solutions being
imposed where we are supposed to deal
with plastic plastic that can no longer
be recycled we need to change article 22
26 and the Articles which delegate or
allow for the commission to use
delegated acts in such a manner and
designed in such a manner that for
example the commission has the time
until the end of December to prepare a
delegated act and then it comes into
force on the 1st of
January this is not the way
that you legislate or you build economy
let's be responsible let us amend this
during the vote thank you very
much Philip ol is the next speaker thank
you very much president everybody wants
to work against
waste useless waste and overc
consumption and obviously we can only
agree on reducing the packaging and
these bags and so on but the problem is
implementing it's all or nothing as
usual you know we get into this absurd
making of rules and setting standards
you
know traditional things like the camon
be packaging uh which really are
important for that product and for that
brand uh are being attacked
so we found consensus but there's a lack
of nuance here there's a lack of
knowledge and a lack of Elegance a lack
of and this is typical really of what
the European Union is all about it's
bureaucracy red tape that only knows
about statistics and numbers and wants
to just remove National identities but
we're talking about people here people
and countries with their own
traditions fresa donat's next
speaker this regulation on packaging and
packages waste is part of a raft of
measures for the European green deal
which have set themselves objectives
such as doing way with um fossil fuel
vehicles trying to reduce CO2 emissions
in the atmosphere uh and to try to help
PR the climate those seem to be an
excuse for the commission to move
forward at any cost including the wides
scale destruction of Industry throughout
the European Union this industry has
guaranteed social progress and Welfare
for more than a century even countries
which are more virtuous when it comes to
recycling such as Italy will be forced
to change their productive models within
a very short phase of time so as to
eliminate
plastic The Proposal of
reusing uh packaging for all consumer
products including food stuffs is
economically non-sustainable and
damaging for the environment given the
enormous waste of energy water and
detergent this would involve let's bring
an end to these ideological uh Crusades
let's go back to what Europe's really
about thank you Pascal thank you Pascal
Aron is the next
speaker thank you vice president
commissioner everybody produces each
year about 177 kg of packaging for my
household my wife and children we
produce over 700 k of packaging that's
about the size of a large horse um
living in my kitchen where're aware that
we must bring this down everybody knows
that packaging should be seen as a raw
material that we don't burn that we
don't shift send to Asia but which we
reuse but um as often um we must be
ambitious but feasible the ambitious the
commission text uh was too ambitious we
hear that in debate the left says it's
not enough the right says it's uh it's
all rubbish to use
that term in the middle we say we must
be say that it must be feasible we I've
talked um about the practicalities with
many companies many have said that it's
not flexible enough and we know a bit
more time to create the recycling market
and our product for the packaging needs
to be redesigned uh and we need to have
new packaging models designed these
companies have different uh uh worries
uh apart from uh packaging but they'll
deal with it but they say make it
feasible make it
flexible
because uh if you try to do too much
it'll it'll break down um let's vote for
it tomorrow so that we can vote so we
can meet in the middle so that we can
have a text
which uh de deals and brings down this
mountain of packaging
waste thank you very much a varti has
the
floor thank you
president I share the fundamental points
put forward by the commission who says
that prevention must be at the very top
of the hierarchy of waste which
underpins the whole proposal
nevertheless I do know that the
commission proposal does have some uh
drawbacks regarding the ways in which we
should achieve our objectives in
particular for those sectors such as the
food
sector which have very specific
characteristics I would remind you that
the current directive sets out the need
for member states to bring about a major
increase in terms of their recycling
targets some countries such as my own
did this with enormous efforts and
investment the current proposal has
however actually charts out the opposite
way
forward setting out binding Targets in
terms of
reuse
and the suggestion is that this would
always be the best environmental choice
but this would be questioned because of
the enormous amount of water this would
involve it's important that we uh look
but we show some courage in recognizing
the efforts taken by certain member
states in term terms of recycling while
at the same time guaranteeing absolute F
food safety when it comes to the food
our citizens
consume thank you the floor goes to Max
oril commissioner
colleagues each European generates about
189 kilos of waste packaging per year
and it's going it's going up and up so
managing uh the the waste is part of our
planet's preservation plan in this
context this regulation on packaging is
an important step towards reducing waste
revising the standards will allow us uh
to be Innovative in uh
sustainable M materials for packaging
and also in recycling collection and
reuse as well where possible but if this
is succeed every citizen and in every
territory is going to have to be
actively involved so let's make sure
that everybody really takes it on board
Spirits are in the overseas territories
represent the Excellence and knowledge
and knowhow of these territories and
they deserve special attention with
regard to the ReUse obligation for
bottles I'm not convinced that this is a
measure that is really suited to our
Ultra peripheral regions so with the
vote tomorrow we can try and find the
right balance between the environment
and adopting uh functional rules
rul
before we invented the so-called green
policies before we moved all production
from Europe into China Vietnam and other
countries we used to have a few
kilograms of uh packaging waste per
capita now we have almost 200 kilos of
packaging waste
we adopt legislation uh very frequently
but the fact is that we have growing
mountains of
waste first we tried to uh have a
differentiated collection of uh waste we
have separate boxes for glass for
cardboard for uh Plastics but what is
the
truth from none of this waste is being
recycled
um the most
Plastics waste is only waiting in the uh
storages in order to be uh transported
somewhere or being
um taken to Fire and every fire is
visible from the
space Miss thank you president
commissioner colleagues in Europe the
waste mountains are getting bigger the
reason for that is uh one of the reasons
is packaging uh material 40% of
the um plastic um and 40% of the paper
and 50% of the plastic is packaging and
that's why we need this new regulation
on packaging I think this what's good
about this proposal is that from 2030
all packaging must be recycling
recyclable I think this proposal is good
secondly that reuse and deposit systems
must be um built up in all member states
and thirdly it's good that the cycle the
share of recycling in plastic must be is
being um increased what's not good is
the bands for uh individual packaging
format we're talking about sugar for and
cream for coffee it's no sense in having
uh labeling for um
beer bottles Etc that has been corrected
is important that this topic which in
certain member states has been set
up and which serves these recy circul
economy that these can um be maintained
over years and decades um uh circular
systems have been built up and that
shouldn't be counted thank
you thank you next speaker is Neil
fugang
we are drowning in uh waste and
packaging and we it's going up since
2009 the amount of waste in Europe has
gone up by
20% friends
I'm I'm I'm sick of all the plastic in
the nature and the water I think many
people are uh sick of it in or or who's
in Denmark people are sick of it and
there's a system now where there are
reuse cups instead of uh takeaway cups
if you get a cup in a restaurant in
orus you have a depos deposit there's
deposit system where you can um deposit
the cup and get the money back that's so
these cups are not U uh thrown away in
nature if or's can do it we can do it
throughout Europe so let's get a law
which phases out a single-use plastic
let's do something good both for people
and nature and and let's uh drop the um
exceptions which the plastic Lobby wants
to have let's get plastic out and let's
get nature and the environment in thank
you thank you very much next speaker is
Mr Ian
Stanek ladies and gentlemen the
legislation on packaging and packaging
waste is an important Milestone uh
towards uh sustainable uh packaging
economy in Europe it affects every
producer distributor and consumer what
is key factor is uh to uh emphasize uh
uh Level Playing Field for everybody
this legislation extends uh the
obligations uh uh for manufacturers of
uh drinks uh including alcoholic drinks
but it shouldn't discriminate one from
another uh it is important uh for uh
equal terms and Level Playing Field to
apply to everybody uh the objective of
10% of uh reusable um packaging and 25%
by uh 2040 is achievable and during this
time uh we can uh fine tune and fix uh
all uh the deficiencies and I think we
shall uh set Level Playing Field for
everybody at this stage and I want to
thank everybody who shared this opinion
and support this draft bana
Boran Miss borzan has the
floor thank you
chair each of us generates
188 kilog of uh waste and in the last 10
years the quantity of waste increased by
20% we really need to start using the
resource resources we have in a more
intelligent way and we need to protect
our
environment uh in inflation
times products are placed
in packagings to fool the consumers
because the contents is smaller uh we
need to stop this practice uh there are
the fake bottoms unnecessary letters or
other sorts of uh packagings who aim is
to fol the consumers only when we return
home we realize that we made a mistake
and then it's already too late with this
legislation we are going to solve this
problem and we will uh enable our
consumers to get the what they paid
for thank you president our cheeses our
French cheeses are Lov throughout the
world but who can imagine a camon or
mondor without its wooden packaging
plastic wrapping would really be
aesthetically unpleasing and makes no
sense uh environmentally what we're
trying to do here is ensure that the
internal Market functions properly so
that we can move towards sustainable
wrapping and
packaging but you know we we're talking
about something that really guarantees
the quality so when we're talking about
the scope this has to be taken into
account there's other products as well
not just cheese from other countries
other products in other countries are
facing the same dilemma we need to
protect our environment but not to the
detriment of the uh specificities of
each member State and you know this is
working against their
prosperity so let's stop all this gold
plating let's be more Discerning in our
uh
legislation Cesar Len as the next
speaker
thank you President we clearly have a
problem when it comes to packaging waste
in the European Union this regulation
we're talking about addresses this
problem I think we've had good
negotiations good agreement which
combines ambition and
flexibility I think our society and in
particular in manufacturing industry we
have to make more efforts first of all
to reduce the volume of
packaging uh dear colleagues we have to
reduce the enormous numbers of
unnecessary packaging we have to promote
reuse we also have to improve
recycling we have to ensure that all
packaging either goes back or it's
recycled and
finally our citizens deserve more and
better information so we very much
welcome a mandatory uh labeling
describing the origin of the packaging
our Citizens need this information
certain sectors wine Ceramics fruit and
vegetables and so need all of
this so I think when this regulation is
finally adopted I think it will be good
news for the green New Deal and for the
European
Union thank you next speaker is Maria
spiri commissioner dear colleagues
needless to say that we have to put an
end on the dramatic increase of
packaging waste generation but at the
same time we have to take into account
the concerns coming from the market
various stakeholders raised the issue of
effective implementation of packaging
regulation according to my opinion it is
critical to clear out that recyclable
and reusable options are complementary
opting for the more circular packaging
model should be the key objective of
this regulation definitions of
recyclability and high quality of
recycling still need to take into
account both scientific evidence and the
Practical experience of well functioning
recycling system for certain materials
we can't deal with a circular model if
it is not recognized all the associated
benefits of packaging made of renewable
material for instance it will allow
biobased packaging to fulfill its
potential legal certainty is much needed
also without definition of composite
packaging of plastic packaging to ensure
compliance with the minimum recycling
content Targets in plastic packaging
finally it would also be important for
food packaging or packaging used for
food ingredients especially when it
comes Toes that should not be subjected
to to reuse targets as those cannot be
properly sterilized to be used in safe
condition and without inuring cross
contamination thank you very much Mr
President thank you and the next speaker
is Miss MRA
kri dear chair dear commissioner there
is too much packaging and waste uh
produced today we all consumers in Union
we see that how there are many good ways
to reduce the waste through the
packaging that is measured right avoid
miniscale packaging for example in the
hotels recycling packaging material so
they don't end up on the waste field uh
and then also uh circular economy can
diminish needs for new materials uh
through the ReUse also we can find it
somewhere reuse doesn't fit everywhere
but there are ideas for that one also
the be promoted we have single use
plastic regulation is place in place but
it's very narrow so I expected something
more to come but what we see now that it
was panning paper it was panning
composite and and actually what we see
in McDonald's in France adding plastic
cups that comes from oilbased fossils
that is imported from outside of Europe
and is not recyclable so I hope the
trialog the best of luck not to replace
reusable renewable paper and composite
with the plastic that is now happening
good
luck thank you very much we're now
coming to the catdi and as I said we can
take all the colleagues and we start we
beginning with h
p commissioner s we said that our goal
is to bring down packaging waste
um
um by having multi-use options it's
important to have standardized life
cycle analysis there's many studies
every producers have their own studies
with the wished for results by to the
commission um which
have listen
to RI to toval on life cycle analysis
make sure that you uh your analysis are
based on comparable scientific
debasis basis and then we can have a
better
debate I've
always said that we have to harmonize
ambitious objectives with the reality on
the
ground of course we should want to try
and reduce packaging waste however the
quantity of waste and packaging is
proportionate to the quantity of food or
product that we're consuming so
excessive consumption is the problem and
we're aware of that commissioner
colleagues we should take into account
in our regulation the recommendations of
those who know what this is all
about Amendment 417 for example provides
for exemptions for high performing
packaging and not all packaging is
adapted to all products we need to take
that into account and Tom tomorrow when
we vote we need to be uh you know aware
of these uh differences and uh we need
to improve on the commission's proposal
because it they weren't 100% objective
nor realistic miss
Ma
thank you president commissioner ladies
and gentlemen I can see the need to
update the existing rules so that we can
effectively fight with excessive waste
from packaging but the direction chosen
is a right one yes but the pace at which
it is supposed to be implemented and the
over ambitious objectives it all renders
it impossible to implement please note
that in the draft we're lacking
reference to to various circumstances in
particular member states the new
objective should be realistic in the
first should be measurable doable
feasible technically while following the
idea of of uh sustainable development so
we should also take into consideration
social aspects and economic aspect and
member states must be given
leeway with respect to Extended
responsibility of producers deposit
schemes and Waste Management I also warn
you against additional red tape which
will be negative for businesses that's
something that we should remember as
well actually many of those burdens
included there are totally Superfluous
if packaging is collected and recycled
adequately thank you
Susan thank you
president when I hear that the European
commission has set itself High Ambitions
I I get scared I would prefer to see
slightly less ambitious programs with a
bit more firmly rooted in reality a bit
more
balanced I'm delighted to be a member of
the European Parliament and together
with my colleagues I've spent years
explaining to my fellow citizens how
they should go about uh sorting their
waste and why it's a good thing now lots
of countries have achieved their
objectives on recycling now we're being
told no let's change everything let's
force ciens of Europe to change their
habits and above all let's cause a real
production
problem not to mention the food industry
farming
catering either because of bad faith or
because of ignorance they've created an
enormous threat to these industries
undermining the European economy the
Italian
economy we're talking about 600 million
euros of uh Euros a year 1.3 million
companies with hundred or millions of
employees let's think carefully about
this thank you very much
president The carar Coffee Cup project
is an amazing voluntary initiative by
small businesses in the southwest of
Ireland they recently implemented a
project that now includes over 50
businesses moving away from single use
coffee cups before the project started
Kar was thrown away 1 million cups per
year Louise Burne from the kar coffee
cup project said often packaging and
single use items are not recycled or
composited they simply become General
waste even if this waste Source was
managed correctly it's only in use for
an average of 13 minutes considering the
impact associated with deforestation
water stress manufacturing
transportation and waste management she
said I don't think it's just its use
justifies its existence she said I would
argue that watering down goals and
policies sends the wrong message to
people about political priorities and
the true Global risk of climate change
however yet again EP have joined forces
with the far right to do exactly that to
water it down ambition at the behest of
the private packaging industry pretty
sad mark tabella
please the European Green New Deal is an
important priority some people are
stubborn and saying that it's all going
well and that everything will turn out
well in the end
that's simply not true amongst all these
measures those we've been trying to roll
out so as to ensure that future
Generations have a chance of surviving
new rules in the European Union
regarding packaging and de facto efforts
to fight against packaging at its source
all of those are important on average
every European as we've heard generates
188 kilos of waste per year that's
enormous that's 11 kilos more than last
year which says a lot and demonstrates
that new legislation is
necessary given that so many countries
companies simply fail to understand that
the planet's resources are not
inexhaustible and that they always put
their own profits ahead of general
interest we now have no choice other
than to impose strict rules some might
say that nobody else is doing this
around the world I would say to them you
have to start somewhere and if Europe
can be a Pioneer when it comes to
recycling I think we should be proud of
it thank you the next speaker Miss
CL thank you
chair today we are facing a huge
challenge a challenge that will Define
Our Generation management of packaging
and packaging waste we are all aware of
the fact that the quantity of waste
increased from 66 million tons in 20 in
2009 to 70 million tons of waste only 10
years later we need a clear legislation
and legal certainty and we need to
involve all relevant stakeholders
including the E uh Commerce but we have
to be careful with producers this means
that we need to promote packaging which
can be uh recycled but also the
development of infrastructure for
recycling and reuse we need to create an
economy which will um Safeguard our
planet however we have to be realistic
and Achieve what is doable today and we
have to say it clearly the circumstances
are not the same in all EU member states
therefore we need a packaging which will
uh make our planet Greener but at the
same time we need to clearly Define our
priorities Miss Clara
agil thank you president there's no
doubt about it this is a very important
debate our objective of is something
which we all share this is
essential and we have to ensure that
Europe be a Pioneer on this however what
we have to do is to ensure that we can
balance the ambition of these objectives
and they are indeed very ambitious with
the reality which European businesses
face many European businesses have been
investing in research for years now so
as
to improve res
they shouldn't be penalized for that
now we have set ourselves an objective
of
reuse but we should also continue to
promote a high percentage of
recycling at the same time in the
farming in the agricultureal committee
we've tried to find consensus so as to
uh push through certain reforms in this
in these proposals regarding the food
chain we want to use these amendments so
as to to ensure that we can continue to
guarantee food security the traceability
of food stuffs with in full knowledge of
their Origins as well and we should also
avoid food waste and sometimes reuse of
packaging doesn't always help us do that
Ros
con more than 700 companies are at
risk and many thousands of jobs this
would have a negative impact on more
than 30% of Italians those are just some
of the side effects of this absurd
regulation for Italy which has achieved
a recycling rate of
73.3% many years before the objectiv
seted by the European
Union but this isn't enough however uh
in the face of this Preposterous
proposal which Focus so much on reuse
we've talked about the we haven't talked
much about the re of use of water
detergent uh damage and
transport as well as the conserving and
food safety of many food stuffs sages
fruit uh uh packaging for hotels Sports
not to mention the impact on the uh
catering and drink sector the impact of
this is it proportionate with the
efforts no not at all all of this is
wrong in the vote tomorrow we have to
try to reestablish a balance between the
need to reduce packaging and related
waste and the demand demands of
producers the next speaker is Mr Sean
Kelly I come from Kar my native town is
the Tourist capital of Ireland and I'm
very pleased to see reference to it by
my colleague here today there's a very
active tidy towns committee there
including and please to say my wife
people like Johnny Maguire car Foley
party Tracy Lise burdens and former
counselor M Lon and they saw that in
Ireland that 200 million coffee cups in
a population of 5 million were being
used every year the majority of these
weren't recycled weren even composted
that went to landfill and they said they
do something about it and the local
community now over 50 businesses in
growing are now having a cup which is
reusable which they all adhere to saving
a lot in terms of waste and particularly
giveing good example to Society at large
those cups which were open to now Ed 13
minutes of their lifespan this can be
reused and honored as they go along I
think there's a huge example here that
people themselves even if there's no
legislation we do something which is
benefited to society and benefit
particularly in El waste very much thank
you very much and then we continue with
the commissioner commissioner Vino svich
please the floor is yours
honorable members let me start uh with
the very positive first of all truly
thank you for your contributions because
they clearly showed that we all
seriously concerned about the rapid
unsustainable growth in packaging
waste we also understand that our task
to set the framework for a resource
efficient packaging sector is truly
challenging one the linear system of
take make throw away has been wested
itself deeply in our production and
consumption patterns and it will take
considerable efforts and a change in
mindset to bend the curve towards the
circular economy for packaging so we
must ensure that the measures with
significant amplifications for business
are stretching but proportionate that
there is sufficient time for the
transition and that smmes are not
overburdened both citizens and
businesses expect us to act with
ambition and realism and we are
determined more than ever to work
together to ensure that all concerns are
addressed and the commission is here to
help and discuss let me come back
briefly on few individual points that I
think are extremely important
uh to address first of all prices for
consumers I he quite a few
statements on prices for
consumers I ask you to use your common
sense all this shiny new packaging that
we fill our bins with
190 kilg per year this costs money to
deal with so we estimated that with our
measures that we put uh that we have on
the table consumers will actually save1
per person per year in action if we
continue with the same scenario as we
have now would cost 6.4 billion relative
to 2030 and that's cost for the economy
for the society for the
environment very simple less waste less
resources less costs and that's good for
both citizens and the environment
the I've he also quite a few remarks as
regards the impact
assessment that it's not sound that
there is no impact assessment want to
reassure you that impact assessment was
done a very careful one and that the
ReUse targets lead to a decrease of
water consumption and a reduction of CO2
emissions of
1.25 million tons in 2030 the commission
is fully aare that some lcas with a
specific scope on certain sectors and
based on arbitrary model assumptions can
come with different
results the commission proposal though
acknowledges the role of single use
packaging and thus our proposal forsees
a coexistence of both systems
established in a way to reap the maximum
economic and of course
environmental benefits now on
reuse the architecture on of the
commission proposal Builds on
Improvement of both reuse and Recycling
and we cannot be naive that with this
growing numbers of waste that we can
recycle our way out of it I'm very sorry
to take bit more time but I think it is
extremely important to reply to the
questions uh that the members of the
parliament have put forward the last
thing which was very sensitive on some
of the packaging um of some of the
cultural heritage so indeed in the EU
certain food packaging made of wood
textiles keramics are placed on the
market in a very small quantities and
many of them protected by the food
quality legislation so the commission is
aware that such packaging may have
difficulties to be recycled uh at scale
and is open for specific exemptions
notably where certain packaging
materials or formats are required for
specific food and products
finally honorable members let me assure
you there will be no compromises when it
comes to food safety and we duly analyze
the measures to avoid any increase of
food waste and when it comes to the
impacts on the producers of single use
packaging let me recall you that our
approach foresees a coexistence single
use packaging will not disappear our
analysis concludes that volumes for
cardboard and paper based based single
use packaging will Flatline at the
levels they reached a few years ago so
there is no disruption in a business
case because when the regulation kicks
in production levels would be still
higher than a decade
ago honorable members I think we are
united in the task we must do more to
reverse the rising tight of packaging
waste and we must do it as soon as
possible most importantly this will
benefit the environment reduce pollution
and and Safeguard our single Market
let's listen to our citizens and provide
solution and commission is there to do
its atmost to support agreement in the
coming months and of course I count on
you and I trust we can make it sorry for
taking a bit more time thank you
commissioner for answering the
colleagues questions and now we come to
the reporter Neil
thals Mr President dear
commissioner with the commissioner we
have been fighting on many issues before
uh and usually we find Solutions at the
end of the day that was happened last
week and it will happen this week and
will happened next week uh but I think
we should be honest about one
thing this commission has produced twice
the amount of legislation the previous
commiss commission did and that actually
led to a situation where where we are
running again with the commissioner in
seconds blank to the next meeting trying
to find new uh Solutions on another
other problem at the same time we know
that everybody has been working under
severe time constraints and severe time
constraints also in influence the way in
which the impact assessment was done so
and that was seen by the reporter re in
the very beginning when she tried to
find the solution on article 26 and just
to sort of accommodate uh the goals of
the commission with the reality of the
of the
industry another important points we
support the commission's Ambitions
obligation to recycle packaging by 2030
application of extended
resp uh extended respon responsibility
principle on packaging harmonizing lab
labeling introduction of deposit and
return systems and promotion of recycled
content in plastic packaging such
profound changes toward the circular
economy don't happen overnight and for
gree has put all her energy and
experience into ensuring that the
European Parliament vote uh votes within
the short time frame to and to make this
regulation or something feasible for the
economic
operators circular economic of packaging
will help de decouple Economic
Development from the youth use of
Natural Resources contribute to
achieving climate neutrality by
2050 and reduce the eu's economic
strategic dependency on many materials
harmonized rules are key to remove the
barriers for business selling packaging
in several member states or across the
EU caused by differing rules between the
different member states but I think we
have to acknowledge also one
thing during the covid-19 uh EP
epidemy we actually learned a different
way of
Behaving and when human beings learn a
different way of Behaving it's very
difficult to unlearn people from this
Behavior so that's the that's the
project we have in front of us the path
map it out is the right one it's up to
the plenary uh session tomorrow to
confirm this approach and then we see
how we matage together with
commissioner SES the rest of the battle
thank you very much Mr raor and the
debate is now closed and the vote as you
said will be held tomorrow the minutes
of yesterday's sittings and the text
adopted are available are there any
comments no then the minutes are
approved I have to make a small
announcement pursuing to rule 158
paragraph 2 on a proposal from the
president and with the agreement of the
political groups I would like to inform
the house that due to the length of the
voting session the sitting on Wednesday
is extended to uh 11:
p.m. we will now move to the
debates and we are coming to a very
interesting